in the fertile hills of derbyshire
england
one man is cultivating something
unique
i'm gavin monroe i grow furniture
this is our furniture orchard
we've got chairs this side lamps over
here
tables a little further around that way
and all manner of things in between
the original idea came from realizing
that the way that we make furniture now
is that we have to grow the trees for at
least 50 years and then we cut them down
and we make them into smaller and
smaller and smaller bits
before sticking them back together again
why bother with that at all why indeed
gavin trains the branches of young trees
by attaching them to specially made
forms he then grafts them together to
form one solid piece
slowly they grow into fully formed
pieces of furniture but exactly how slow
are we talking for a chair to grow that
takes five to ten years depending on the
species the thing is if you're thinking
about this in the bigger picture then by
the time you've grown your tree for 50
years we'll have at least 10 generations
of chairs rolled out while it seems slow
in real terms of making things out of
wood it's actually pretty quick
when we harvest the trees we're not
killing them the varieties that we use
all grow back again the next year on the
environmental front it's not just
efficient it's uber efficient
well we've only waited 10 years for that
[Laughter]
we've got this lovely curve coming up
here
when we sand this down this little
triangle is going to look gorgeous
you got it yep we can get them into the
workshop and the fun begins on the
production side and we can start to kind
of bring together geometry and nature
the finishing is where we can really let
that shine
and no one can deny that gavin's
furniture is beautiful
but is it functional
not only do we
think that they'll be stronger they'll
be way stronger because they're one
solid piece there's no joints to come
loose
what we're doing here is collaborating
with the trees it's kind of a beautiful
way of working really
[Music]
you